this is the aftermath of an alleged
Russian attack in urdhiv in the
zapparija region authorities carry away
the Dead the victims had come to collect
Aid at this school it's become a
distribution point during the war
in Frontline Villages these centers are
a critical lifeline
all those who could leave and wanted to
have
only the elderly remain every day they
wait for Aid to be delivered but many
here fear these collection points may
become a regular Target
every single day we are shelled we
suffer a great deal I don't know who was
wounded yesterday I rarely go out just
come here to pick up humanitarian Aid I
believe the front line will move further
away from our village
yam pill was once occupied by Russian
forces every building has some sort of
damage and the sound of fighting can
still be heard from here
82 year old Alexandra sergivener stayed
she refuses to leave she remembers when
Russian soldiers were outside her home
they used to ask me granny what do you
need I would say I don't need anything
except peace I saw a young Soldier die
just over there I wish it were me rather
than him he was so very young some
people were buried in their homes
because it was too dangerous to go to
the graveyard Russians and ukrainians
used to be friends why did they do this
to us
The Village used to have a zoo once an
attraction for ukrainians during their
vacations but since the war the animals
were either killed in fighting or
escaped
now this is the last point before it
becomes too dangerous to travel further
locals don't even come this far out
anymore
the Ukrainian military are constantly
passing through here to the front line
as artillery battles take place nearby
the story of this Village is the same as
many others spread across the Eastern
Front Line no electricity no running
water dependent on food Aid and very
little respite from the constant
shedding as I beg Al Jazeera yam pill
eastern Ukraine